sí
bienvenido otra vez ahora que estás
familiarizado con la ley de la lente
simple podemos profundizar un poco más
en el ejercicio anterior
aprendiste que la ley de la lente simple
puede escribirse como y igual a o por
efe / /
- efe así que si el plano de la imagen
de nuestra cámara está a una distancia y
los objetos que están a una distancia o
de la cámara estarán enfocados con
nitidez pero qué sucede con los objetos
que están a otra distancia
bueno pues estarán fuera de foco no
estarán enfocados con nitidez por
ejemplo las hojas que aparecen enfocadas
están a una distancia que cumple con la
ecuación de la lente simple sin embargo
los objetos que aparecen en el fondo
están desenfocados
observa como el desenfoque tiene la
forma de un círculo recuerda que en la
última lección
llamamos a esto el círculo de confusión
pero qué tan grande es el círculo para
responder esta pregunta durante el resto
de esta lección desarrollaremos una
fórmula que describa el tamaño del
círculo a partir de cosas como la
distancia focal de la lente la apertura
y la distancia con respecto al objeto
como hasta ahora examinemos este
problema en 2d y tomemos en cuenta lo
que sucede en un punto p con coordenadas
x 0 l 0 a una distancia o de la lente
podemos inter secar los rayos paralelo y
principal para hallar el punto donde p
entra en foco llamémosle y recuerda que
cada lente tiene una apertura que limita
los rayos que entran en la cámara
coloquemos un punto en el centro de
nuestra lente y un punto d en la parte
superior de la apertura en otras
palabras d es el radio de nuestra
apertura por lo tanto todos los rayos de
luz provenientes de p que pasan a través
de d
terminarán concentrándose en el mismo
punto
y si el plano de la imagen está a esta
distancia y entonces p estará enfocado
nítidamente pero si el plano de la
imagen está a una distancia mayor y
prima digamos aquí entonces la imagen
que está en p queda desenfocada dentro
del área señalada como ves en el
diagrama esta distancia
abc del límite el tamaño del círculo de
confusión es decir bs es el radio del
desenfoque hagamos una pausa aquí para
que puedas familiarizarte con este
diagrama antes de que terminemos
nuestros cálculos